I talked a little bit today about
valgrind valve wine which is a memory
checker just a quick how-to a video
basically I'm gonna preempt with a few
quick things of how to kind of get it
running on Ubuntu in general I am using
Zorin OS which is a Debian distribution
that's kind of what these instructions
are geared to anything with Debian I did
have to install Val grind sudo apt-get
install Val grind the current release is
314 so if we run valgrind new version
I'll see him on 3/11 which apparently
has a bug with random device so I'm
running into that but before that just
he'd be able to even run it you've got
to do a few things so you have to you
have to compile with debug - JEE so I
had to add this to my make file where I
decided to add it rather because with my
normal see flags on I don't have it
debugging so if I run debug or you know
make debug it appends this - G - my C
flags which is - geo and everything a
building that way you can run about
right cuz you can only run this pin
check with - G on there so that's the
first thing you got to do is make sure
you have those flags and this is a
simple way to do it this is further
explained and let me see here here we go
pretty this explains it pretty well but
there's more details so someone asked
the question alright how do i how I do
this the answer is you basically make a
command that has it appending it so
there you go that's confusing check the
manual you look at these target specific
variables and it will explain it further
but basically you can just do something
like this if used I used plus equals and
sub equals that way the pins
yeah like it says here alright so last
thing so I go to my program it's on
there so there it is alright so take a
look so I'm gonna do make clean and I'm
gonna make debug and it's gonna build
everything with - G okay so we'll do Val
grind you got to do this on your
executable my executable name is I think
DM power so I'll do valve rind - - leak
check equals yes can you - for V for
verbose I guess I'll do that and oh you
can always do - - help real quick if you
if you want to know more about what
these do so just FYI okay now I have a
bit of a problem on my program and okay
so tells me the options that pulled in
this is all the verbose stuff this is
just a lot of might be handy but what
you're usually mainly looking for is
this leak summary here looks pretty good
but it's not as good as it seems because
I have this unrecognized instruction and
it it gives it a signal for have just
killed the program so why didn't show
any leaks it is also killing the program
before it really does anything and
that's because of this random device
supposedly this is fixed in later
versions of Orion if you're not using
random device at all you might not have
this problem at all
well anyway that's how you run valgrind
and that's how you do it on your program
you can try it with these options - if
you want more info but as long as it
succeeds and doesn't have this illegal
opcode it'll tell you where your memory
leaks
or when you have well alright good luck
hopefully you can fix up your memory
leaks without Ryan hope you enjoyed this
video don't forget to give it a like it
helped you subscribe to this channel for
more random coding shenanigans and
tutorials and have a good day and keep
going